graphic warning ahead oh that last shot
we are joined today by the overall
visual effects supervisor
for the boys it's so fun to see you guys
reaction it's a whale
exploding from a boat hitting it this
was very very complicated to pull off
for so many reasons you guys don't even
know
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
episode stick around in the end to see
how you can save 15
off your order hey everybody welcome
back to another episode of visual
effects artists react
we are joined today by a very special
guest stephen fleet
now stefan is the overall visual effects
supervisor for
the boys on amazon and it's a total
honor and privilege to have you on the
show thanks so much for joining us uh
thank you guys
i mean to me it's an honor it's honored
to be with you guys thank you so much
for having me
stefan tell us a little bit more about
what you do i figure out how we're going
to shoot it technically
and creatively and i'm there on set work
with my team on set work with the
directors everybody come back
and i work with like seven to ten visual
effects companies at any given time
to get the show done it's definitely the
best thing i've
ever worked on in my life it's that
golden triangle great people to work
with
great content and uh you know the money
is not bad
i gotta give everybody a big warning
here if you haven't watched the boys
spoil the heck out of it so you should
get on it it's a great show
are we going right into the whale
literally one of the most notorious
sequences from season two
is that like a full cg water full cg
that is a full cg water full cg
environment um ilm london
did all of this work wow really we
really try and bury the cg as much as
possible on the show so it's not
noticeable as much as you can in this
day and age
and what's great is camera movement
helps a lot with that it's like a magic
trick like we're doing over look over
here you know so
the way the camera movement the splashes
of water on the lens all this visual
noise adds to a better shot the only
thing that's not cg is part of chase
crawford the deep so what happened was
he was shot on a blue screen outdoors in
a garage i insisted that we shoot it
outdoors
okay because i think if you're doing a
daylight exterior even if you're doing
green screen and trying to put place
together you should really try and shoot
outside because trying to get studio
lights to recreate the sun
it's just it's it's tough man it turns
out light bulbs are not as bright as
fusion exactly yeah exactly yeah there
you go yeah you'll get some pushback
sometimes because
you start thinking about the logistics
of how visual effects works in tv what's
great about it is you can do a lot of
indoors
and they call that rain cover so all of
a sudden if it's raining and they don't
know what to shoot that day they're like
oh let's go shoot some driving comps on
the
thing or whatever you know and we don't
do driving comps on the show by the way
that's a mandate for me and eric yeah
it's all real driving all right i was
about to say i was like i
i look like real driving to me i think
green screen and blue screen is
way overrated and it's like you're gonna
end up probably rotoing some of the
green screen stuff out anyway back when
i was an artist we would joke that like
you know green screen is a great
place holder for roto but especially
with some of the stuff we get back where
they would you know take the green
screen and like fold it up like out of
the back of the truck and just like roll
it out
and you're just like ugh try yeah
so for the for the actual explosion here
though like
yeah it's a whale exploding from a boat
hitting it i know
so this is what's so great about this
show if i were on most other shows
we probably would have had like a tennis
ball for the whale but no we built they
built a whale set like they built a
full-on whale set
once they hit it and the boat goes into
it in that profile shot
that's the real set oh really yeah we
added some blood and we added some water
spray
but that's actually doubles on a special
rig that our special effects team who's
awesome
they pulled the boat in the pre-existing
hole and had 150 gallons of fake blood
there's gopros that we painted out on it
we shot like it's all these different
angles and stuff yeah yeah
that shot right there really sells the
real so the profile one and the one
behind
it are both real even the mouth opening
up like that real
yeah the mouth it was a it was an
animatronic whale the tail and the mouth
could move
they did build this practical whale set
to work as an exterior and an interior
so when you see the stuff
inside the whale it's the same set we
did minimal visual effects work to to
cover up a little add a little bit more
wetness we made some of those organs
pump i was about to say that that heart
but a lot of that especially like all
the blood on them
all the guts around them that's all real
man like our team you know our makeup
guys and our costume guys are out there
just
dumping blood on our cast and poor jack
who plays huey um it's a kind of a
running joke that we just cover him in
blood like
all the time sometimes it's so important
for the actors and the camera and
everything to experience it it's just
it's hard to explain it's like a
different feeling
oh [ __ ] diabolical hey listen if you
have
someone that you think you should be on
the show leave a comment down below and
we'll do our best to try to get them on
the show uh
ma'am your nose
oh that last shot oh this is like oh
it's she's still there she's still
squirting out blood
so fun to see you guys reaction the
special effects team
we developed this way back in season one
when we blew up translucent they have
what we call the blood lollipop
and they'll bring a stick out and i have
them place it right where the head was
with an explosive that goes in all
directions
and they do a blood element for me on
location they built a cg head and a
brain and then they did a shatter
on all of them so we have those elements
every blood thing was a simulation and
it's kind of sometimes you throw them
out there and see what sticks
you take five or six of them and stack
them together to sort of dial up and
down mist versus goop
we also created what we call like the
the necklace which is that meaty flap
that comes oh the necklace
[Laughter]
we spent a lot of time in r d research
and development on this one to come up
with what we thought was
a really cool impactful head explosion
i was tipped off early that in the later
episode like we're going to do a bunch
more of it
so my pitch to the visual effects
companies the company called rocket
science was let's spend the time here on
this
because i'm gonna get you guys a lot of
this down the line so you put all of
that work into that first headshot so
that this scene
could happen you have five minutes to
make your openings
i i love this shot because it takes that
split moment of like
yeah you get actual reaction time that's
a great example of
why special effects is really important
because that's real we blended that in
with the
[Applause]
it cg keeps going and going and going
one of the key ingredients here i feel
for these head shots are the fact that
you do keep just like a couple frames of
the original plate of their head
splitting apart and i can see it it's
only just like a couple frames but i can
see it
and how them two are literally just like
standing in the middle of it going huh
this is strange
what an odd tuesday this is a great this
is one of my um
proudest accomplishments of season two
from a supervision standpoint
the thing about production especially
even a big show like the boys you've got
a time limit we had a limited amount of
time in this space we knew
we were gonna have to go fast you have a
lot of people it gets very complicated
really fast
the way you got to plan it is you always
you plan your
your plan a your plan b then you're like
c d e and f
because things are going to go wrong and
you're going to have to start like
you know shooting from the hip if you
will so i knew that the first couple
booms or what i'm going to call hero or
the most important visual effect shots
they're going to hold the longest
and anytime you hold on something for a
longer period of time and visual effects
it's got to look real you got to spend
more time on set to make sure you get
what you need
but again way back in that first episode
we pretty much figured out the
the magnitude like how how far it's
going to explode
the amount of blood the necklace and all
that stuff so they had a template
basically and so what you see is a
linear progression and we spent the most
time on these first two shots
and then as the day went we had less and
less time i was like all right it's time
to shoot from the hip
but i had a plan i love coming to set
prepared with ideas and backup ideas
that's my favorite shot in the scene
because
we had no time to do it didn't have time
to do plates or green screen
all that stuff and like how do we get
this done so i was like okay if we get
her
up against that flat wall and really
just compose the one shot and have her
duck down and keep on the wall for just
enough frames to get a clean plate out
of it
we can roto her and build the head into
it as one shot so there's only one plate
here we didn't have time to do the blood
lollipop or any of that stuff so this is
just
something giving you one shot this is
like this is all you get is all material
you get
make something happen right but i knew
you know i was there and they were
cool enough to respect me and you know
like say hey how do we do this
the arterial squirt that was like the
the button the little
the cherry on top i i did that little
squirt one time on the lord of the rings
video
like six years ago see there you go my
favorite part about that shot though is
like as she hits the ground
her necklace as you called it like flaps
yeah yeah like flapping
someone on social media called it the
head wedding which i thought was
brilliant
head wedding is great
[Music]
nick you asked me a hard question he
asked me why people should subscribe to
this channel
and i think people should subscribe if
they like watching the videos and want
to see them on a regular basis
so if you're not subscribed and you
enjoy the videos please consider doing
so
so there's one more shot i want to look
at from the boys and again
graphic warning ahead if the exploding
heads wasn't enough for you but
you'll see what i mean
[Applause]
[Music]
holy
when i saw this the first time i was
just like
i couldn't believe it this was very very
complicated to pull off
for so many reasons you guys don't even
know we did not have time to film this
scene
when we were shooting this episode so we
came back way later
in toronto in november of 2019 to film
this scene
on what ended up being the coldest day
in history in november in toronto it was
something like
negative seven degrees celsius and it
had snowed the day before so what you're
also seeing in addition to all these
wonderful visual effects is a complete
replacement of environments
wow to get rid of snow uh pretty much
breath
removal yeah really everyone's breathing
i've never even thought about this and
cross my mind is a thing that one
effects artists might have to do yep
bless
the bg talent and actors for this scene
that had to stand
out there pretending like they weren't
freezing to death
[Applause]
so when he lands that's a typical
example of how we do landing so it's
digi double into real
uh anthony's kind of got his uh shtick
down for jumping up and down now we've
developed that over the years
but his cape flows down behind him so
that had to have been a digital cape
yeah yeah we do digital cape a lot on
this show um because it helps with the
performance and the blending of it
so the eye lasers like part of me is
like oh this is like
the intro to the effects like it's the
lightsaber tutorial
are you guys elevating beyond that here
or is it just one of those simple things
like you know this is all it needs what
we try and do with
super powers especially super powers
that exist in other
properties what we really try to do is
work off camera properties and a lot of
shots
we really interact with the lenses and
the lens flaring as realistically as
possible
using optical flares uh that plug-in
oh yeah thank you andrew kramer hey
what's up andrew
kramer here and then we spend a little
bit of extra time trying to get the eyes
to look
a little more subsurfacy like it's
underneath the eye not just topical
but it's very important when it's light
effects from me
to have that relationship with human
skin and and the direction of light
that's it's really important to try and
get that
this one shot of him starting to swipe
to people it's a lock off we added the
camera shaking post
it's it's plate work he's on a green
screen and then
we had our extras run we did that plate
then we had
12 stunt people go out there and do
pratfalls like falling like they're
getting lasered
and we moved them all over to the left
so if you look over to the left you've
actually got
stunt people that then turn into digital
people that if you frame through it or
maybe a little too still actually right
and then you get the cg blood that
covers them up quickly so you don't see
that much cg and then you think of
things you can put on top so we made the
sign
and we cut through the top of it because
one of the things with homelanders
lasers is always how it affects the
environment it's easy to say okay he's
going to cut someone in half but then
what about everything behind them
yeah so the top shots in a sense were
easier to figure out because
we knew we were far away enough that the
cg would hold up we have kind of a rule
on the show where if they're this big
we can go cg but if they're medium or
closer we really try and avoid
cg people as much as possible and then
these are we had all of our extras lying
in the ground
and do a plate for us covered in blood
and then we did matte painting work on
top of it
these shots were tough to pull off
actually um and what ended up really
kind of being the kiss for these was
that little embers that fly in front of
them
is a inherent lack of movement to map
paintings and it's difficult to
get the motion in there so you try and
add little flame pockets of flame and
embers and things like that
it was like this crowd shot's insane
you're like i had to paint out their
breath
yes we did
[Music]
oh hey sorry i didn't hear you there
thanks to today's sponsor
raycon so i actually use these whenever
i'm riding on a onewheel like commuting
to work you know it takes an hour to get
here so
these are great for that because i don't
have any wires along my neck to get
caught in my backpack or whatever
and they isolate the sound of the wind
going across my ears
that is critical raycon earbuds started
about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market
they sound just as amazing as other top
audio brands you might know
they give you six hours of play time
they have seamless bluetooth pairing
along with more bass
and a more compact design for a
comfortable noise isolating fit
recons make a great holiday gift because
it's something that they can use every
day
for work or play at home or on the go
now is the time to get the best prices
of the year on raycons but hurry because
this offer is available
only for a limited amount of time click
the link in the description or go to
byracon.com
corridor crew to see how you can save 15
off of your order
that is byracon.com corridor crew links
in the description check it out
i like them and i think you will too
seven thank you so much for joining us
on the show i want to shout out your
instagram channel it's actually really
interesting you have a lot of good
behind the scenes photos on there
among other things so guys go check out
uh stefan steffenfleet on instagram
we'll have a link down in the
description below
feel free to shoot him some questions if
you want to maybe maybe
no not sure just
if i don't get to them right away just
uh understand that i get a few but yes i
would love it if you guys could
um i uh i try and put up really cool
content as much as i can for whatever
i'm working on but are you telling me
that once
season three begins production we might
see some sneak peeks on your instagram
maybe i can't promise that uh maybe is
enough
i'll take it well thanks so much for
being on the show thanks guys thank you
very much